Fullmetal Alchemist is freaking sneaky
okay oh let's do some light-headed
adventure for the first four chapters
and then
are my emotions a joke to you this
chapter has left a void in my soul and
the only thing that can feel it is more
of this incredible story but I'm getting
a little ahead of myself so let's take a
step back when I grew up I spent a lot
of time watching Dragon Ball and not a
lot of time watching anything else and
over the last three years I've tried to
fix that by covering some of the most
respected crazy traumatic and popular
manga in circulation today however I've
not yet come across anything quite like
this before Fullmetal Alchemist is a
story that sent its completion in 2010
has been widely praised as perfect and
in addition to you guys asking for it
every single day for the last three
years straight this story has also
featured as the number one anime on many
high-profile lists across the web which
means for the next three videos I will
be for the very first time trying to
figure out if it's deserving of this
praise reading and sharing my first
impressions of hiromu arakawa's sneaky
and deeply upsetting supposed
Masterpiece Full Metal Alchemist take a
seat everyone this should be fun
all right so like I said the first five
chapters of the story took me completely
by surprise and just for transparency
I'm going to be writing sections of this
as I read them I have no idea what
happens after chapter five yet but I
figured I'd let you all know what I
thought about the first five chapters
because it was a really interesting
beaten switch to me and by interesting I
mean sick and twisted but I digress this
manga has the strongest first page I've
ever read it illustrates the singular
event that kick-starts this entire story
all the while interweaving the core
message of it in just one page and four
panels arikawa tells a story of
catastrophe realization Despair and
Consequence the likes of which I've
never seen so concisely conveyed before
I've read a lot of manga on this channel
some truly great pieces of Storytelling
however when I tell you all that this is
the single strongest first page I've
read I want to emphasize that fact as
true for example I got chills when I
read this line for humankind cannot gain
anything without first giving something
up in return Beyond this the first four
chapters are largely centered around
Standalone stories that we as readers
believe to be unrelated to one another
at this point in time they involve our
two main characters Edward Elric and his
younger brother alfons as they travel in
search of something called the
Philosopher's Stone to right the wrongs
of their past the first chapter contends
with the antics of one self-appointed
religious figure known as father
carnella one who claims he can raise the
dead to which Edward says don't like the
sound of that now that's subtle but it's
a really nice piece of exposition
expressed through character expression
it suggests Edward's negative experience
with such a venture and it just really
makes me want to lean in and learn more
about this world I think what I love
about this manga also is that for these
first four chapters or so it tries to
hide the horror of this world for the
most part behind humorous at work and
some truly great storytelling but at the
end of the day the true nature of this
story always manages to seep through the
cracks in chapter 1 a young woman called
Rose wishes for father cornello to
resurrect her deceased boyfriend it's
very heavy subject matter certainly not
what I expected from a first chapter but
what follows again alludes to something
more harrowing in Edward and Al's pasts
one that could explain their physical
state presently furthermore there's some
god-like comparisons used here also but
not in the way that you'd expect the
comparison is made between Edward and
Icarus who famously failed at his
mission despite his greatest and most
ambitious efforts to reach the heavens
above furthermore this story contained
in chapter one is sort of perfect in its
placing much like the townsfolk we the
readers don't know of alchemy and how
it's used and once we see what Fuller
Canelo can do we accept that there must
be some legitimacy to his claims of
divinity and what bonds us with Edward
and Alphonse from the get-go is their
lifting of the cloak on this con man and
his hoax on this town there are of
course other stories like the mining one
in chapter 3 which paints this world in
30 Shades of Gray the government being
the antagonist in this instance it seems
that everyone in this world is fair game
if their motives are misplaced which
honestly just makes things that much
more interesting to me but no matter
what I keep returning to the conclusion
of chapter 2. it's explained to us that
Equivalent Exchange is the rule with
which this story abides by that in order
to gain one thing something of equal
value must be offered up in return I
mentioned this because the one rule of
this world sort of defines these two
boys in their Journey Ed and Al or more
specifically Edward the character
arikawa writes spectacularly well
foreign
[Music]
to show you what I mean there are two
quotes I want to examine and the first
is from this exchange between Rose and
Edward now disillusioned following
cornello's exposure she's emotionally
unable to let her boyfriend go having
held on to hope for so long only to be
let down at the very end what Edward
says to her in response to this begging
can't come off as cold but speaks to the
harsh reality of this world and the
reality he's lived within alongside his
brother all this time saying that she
has to figure out what her next step is
alone to stand up and walk and unlike
them Edward and Al she has at least
strong legs to take her to where she
needs to go suggesting that Edward
believes she got off easier than he did
the second quote I want to draw
attention to is a blink and you miss it
quip in chapter 4 while on the train
Edward says to Al that you can't move
forward if you keep regretting the past
this line is played for Laughs quite
obviously in this scene but even in the
comedy of this manga resides the DNA of
these characters because this philosophy
speaks to the type of person a Edward is
he's quick to certain provocations
Hands-On and resourceful someone who
thinks he always has an answer and when
things go wrong he moves on with
conviction trying to do his best to make
amends moving forward for without that
mindset he'll forever get nothing done
and fixate on the past these four
chapters are quite lighthearted in Parts
but again are permeated by seemingly
innocuous levels of Darkness that is
until we get to chapter 5. yeah okay we
get the picture this episode is [__]
with a capital f where all the other
chapters had darkness in their
background with this it's the very
literal subject matter when the two boys
arrive from their eventful trip their
focus is squarely on bio Alchemy or more
specifically to seek it out to which
they are pointed in the direction of one
show talker
he's introduced as the sewing life
Alchemist for having at one point two
years ago created a chimera a fusion of
two or more creatures that could talk
and that isn't even remotely the most
screwed up thing in this chapter not by
a long shot and I think that's sort of
the idea the purpose of these first five
chapters are to establish the main Duo
reveal how moral they are and in the
background allude to something far more
severe and dark I'm not even kind of
exaggerating that when it was revealed
that show Tucker sacrificed his wife his
dog and his daughter for the sake of his
work this manga evoked a fear deep
within me the likes of which I never
even got from berserk and I think it has
to do with what these five chapters do
best establish a precedent and then boom
contrast the near misses become
extremely tense and the deaths will they
hit much harder too
so it's right around here we leave the
tutorial area of the story and
everything really starts to open up to
us we learn about the politics and the
history of a group known as the
ishpalans we learn more about gluttony
envy and lust and what's more is we get
to see some really clever animation it's
not flashy or anything but when Scar
shatters Edward's arm Ed moves to crawl
backwards but Falls because he's missing
his arm it's a very small detail but
it's one that I appreciate greatly it's
great character acting but back on the
topic of context and setting generally
speaking this isn't so much a story with
clear-cut sides we've been bonded to
many in the military like Mustang
Armstrong and Hawkeye among others but
we can also sympathize with what's going
on with the ish behind formerly known as
Scar and moreover the trio of glut lost
an Envy seemed to be against him too but
yeah that's all I got for now time to go
back to reading five hours later all
right I'm after reading a bunch more and
there's a mystery of foot everyone and
we meet a girl called Winery that has
such a cool design with with her
jumpsuit and then a really nice guy dies
my head hurts alright let's get into it
things might seem complex right now but
it kind of isn't which is interesting
because this story doesn't really pack
itself full with information at least
not in any obvious way and I think
that's perhaps the most clever thing
about this story that I've observed so
far from this point on there's a lot of
mystery surrounding a supposedly evil
plot and its connection to the
Philosopher's Stone that Ed and Al are
searching for and with all of that on my
dinner plate I never felt too full or
overwhelmed by the exposition when I was
reading one piece week to week I would
be writing up like 20 Page documents of
notes taking account of everything that
I thought would be relevant and worth
addressing in a video while also
slamming like six to nine volumes every
four days in a sweat one piece it's
intense it's not for the faith of heart
only those with the strength and will to
become the pirate king that is put with
Fullmetal Alchemist I feel so much more
relaxed this is is one long continuous
story and arakawa is interested in
telling it at her own pace and honestly
it's phenomenal she has such a Keen Eye
for picking out certain intimate moments
and creates space for us to bathe in
them for a little while longer than
other stories I've read through have
given me and this creates so much more
natural investment for me as a reader
because I once so desperately for these
characters that I am now invested in to
get their Happy Endings where Dragon
Ball will be way too busy shoving in
some fight scene or in the case of One
Piece would be way too busy shoving in
as much story as possible it's a good
thing please don't kill me one piece
Community Full Metal Alchemist I am
happy to say has a wonderful balance of
the two and has struck a very satisfying
approach for me I think but enough
generalities I alluded to a mystery
element within this story the
Philosopher's Stone and its supposed
connection with the plot lost and Co are
carrying out on their way to win Reef
for repairs Edina now stopped to talk to
One Dr Marco whose research is directly
tied to what Ed and Al are desperately
looking for this is where the mystery is
turned up to a 11. he uses a
philosopher's stone and is known all
around the area as a guy that can just
heal people with Miracles so to speak
but the conflict here is that Dr Marco
doesn't give Ed anything other than a
riddle to solve and that is to find the
truth that lies within the truth what
the hell does that does that mean Edina
are now faced with solving this mystery
this riddle that leads to the next step
in this web of confusion and someone is
hiding something but what is it suddenly
this story has gone full-blown mystery
Noir and I am all here for it it's such
a rare atmosphere for our Shonen manga
to try and employ so successfully
anyways that riddle meant that the
government I think were using prisoners
as sacrifices to create more philosopher
stones for what reason I still don't
know but this is how far we are Al and
Ed go to investigate but are cut off
before they can discover anything by Two
Souls well okay technically three Souls
but they're all trapped in two suits of
armor they both beat their attackers and
just as Ed's dude is about to Spill the
Beans
[Music]
this story is screwed up despite his
meddling despite his looking for the
truth for some reason they let Edward
live why what's this significance what's
happening okay jokes aside I do have a
theory but you're gonna have to wait a
teeny bit longer
Full Metal Alchemist
when I first saw this Hues guy I was
primed to hate him I was entrenched in
my big brain mode of constantly trying
to suss out and analyze the who the
secret bad guy might be this series
definitely has one somewhere and Hughes
was too nice he loved his family perhaps
too much that could be motive right well
it turns out he's actually awesome and
one of the coolest characters in the
series he gave winry a place to stay
when she was repairing Ed's arm after
the lab 5 fight and he even manages to
deliver one of the most tense scenes in
the series
[Music]
this is another moment where Full Metal
Alchemist turns the drama up to 10 and
we are all drawn in reading through this
segment of the manga I was immediately
convinced of Hugh's innocence and was on
his side one million percent knowing
full well that things were likely going
to go south for the character he found
some key information that blows this
whole case wide open and that's the
problem but he escapes like a mad lad
losing a lot of blood but in the depths
of pain and at the brink of death he
takes every precaution he can to send
the relevant information but he can't
get through it's tragic and not even the
best part of this Fallout Colonel
Mustang and he had this straight guy
funny guy Dynamic thus far and with
Mustang putting up with hughes's Antics
for the sake of Peace but when we were
at the funeral and we see Mustang
reflect on this it's clear to see what
Hughes meant to him specifically and how
badly this impacts him which means
moving forward he's determined to come
to grips with how he died and more
importantly why he died and once he gets
to the crime scene watching his
detective abilities on show was
fascinating it's so easy to write these
kinds of deductions like a super genius
tying inconsequential pieces of
information together in nonsensical
Fashions but arakawa does so here in a
clever but grounded way Mustang observed
that Hughes chose to call from an
outside line because he must have had
reason to perhaps their ranks are
compromised or involved this is a
perfectly reasonable deduction for him
to make furthermore once Armstrong
arrives in the scene Mustang reads in
between the lines of what he says to him
inferring he has a gag order from
someone higher up than even he and
understood from his wording that there
are two murderers on the loose I love
mystery surrounding the government the
Philosopher's Stone and how the
ishmaelens play into it not to mention
Edward and Al it's fascinating and in
making us want to figure this out it
also makes us focus on the World
building all back home
[Music]
I'm gonna be real not much happens in
rust valley in terms of plot progression
but a lot takes place in terms of World
building and context for the narrative
seeing this place where all the main
soldiers go to after the war to get
themselves some nice looking Prosthetics
is both interesting and unsettling with
even the inhabitants saying as much with
a new character called Panini's legs
acting as the launching point that
transport is up this mountain to find
the dude to train Winery in the ways of
making better automail and of course
childbirth
functionally this place acts as a
sobering reminder of the world that they
live in all the while offering up Winery
her little hyperbolic Time Chamber Arc
and when she emerges from this place she
will no doubt make something awesome for
Edward
[Music]
I think a large part of the story's
appeal comes from a tormented World
being seen through the innocent and
well-meaning eyes and actions of two
young children these two Edward Alphonse
are our only anchors to this world and
we make sense of it with the help of
these two and after traveling so far to
get answers to seek out training so that
they may be better equipped to continue
their Journey it made me stop to think
for a moment the following portion of
story concerned itself and deals with
the context surrounding the events that
took place on that day that they lost
everything it's tragic heartbreaking and
every other similar adjective but at the
end of the day this is a story about
Equivalent Exchange will the hardship
the two boys inevitably have to go
through be enough in exchange for
achieving their ultimate goal it isn't
uncommon for Shonen stories to concern
themselves with the protagonists pushing
towards some unreachable goal in fact
it's sort of a staple of the genre and
many other films for that matter the
indomitable Spirit of these characters
as they Take On The World so to speak
whether it be Luffy's journey to become
the pirate king or Goku surpassing his
limits to overcome some great evil the
theme of fighting against impossible
odds is one that's become integral for
many of these stories however what I
believe sets this one apart is that the
goal is something which is described as
quite literally impossible its
impossibility is a staple of the world
its rules and the greater narrative it's
what sets the goal apart from most
others I've read about because where
there was hope in one piece in Dragon
Ball here it seems to be the case that
there is none and the tone of the
narrative seems to reflect that unlike
Goku who just needs to try Hider or
Luffy who needs to keep searching and
adventuring for the one piece that we
are all told time and again exists by
the way when it comes to Edward and his
brother there isn't a clear path forward
and every sign points to this being
impossible which means there's no
obvious Journey Instead This goal is
shrouded in mystery with us as viewers
and indeed these characters uncertain as
to whether even the direction they're
pushing in will get them closer to where
they ultimately want to be or if it's
simply more wasted time normally an
approach like this would leave an
audience in want or at the very least
confused generally speaking we know how
Goku overcomes the next threat training
and practice similar observations and
expectations can be made for the likes
of Luffy however with Edward and Al
there's no expectation Beyond just not
giving up in the face of literal
impossibilities and brilliantly what's
communicated through such a framework is
an impressive and deeply relatable set
of circumstances for me it's a
fascinating take on the genre and one
that grants this tale an air of darkness
and misery that permeates through the
pages I've read but not in a way that's
so overwhelming it detracts from the
experience and as a result at this point
in my adult life where problems with no
obvious solution present themselves more
often than not watching these two
tirelessly search in the face of
unwavering impossibility with Earnest
and optimism was both incredibly
inspirational and tragic
the anime adaptations
while this series like the vast majority
of reviews on this channel focuses on
the original Source material the manga
in this case it would be completely
irresponsible of me to ignore the two
anime adaptations this Series has
received particularly when one of them
has topped every single fan voted best
anime list for over a decade and frankly
it's very easy to see why both are so
beloved regardless of which version you
pick you're going to find yourself
drowning in to see a phenomenally
well-directed and animated scenes these
are exemplary Productions and it's the
quality on its floor rather than its
ceiling that I think is one of the
number one reasons it sustained itself
in people's memories for so long they
are firing on all cylinders in ways few
Studios can sustain particularly across
over four cores of consistent production
and it's how this was achieved as
perhaps one of the most interesting
aspects of both series's Productions and
I am of course referring to it's
Outsourcing the thought of Outsourcing
tends to conjure up thoughts of melting
Productions and poor animation quality
or it's seen as a cheap Corner coding
alternative to in-house creation and
while it's easy to see why that's the
case particularly in the modern era of
anime Productions Outsourcing is not
inherently a Bad Thing take Dragon Ball
Z for example almost all of his episodes
are outsourced to Studios outside of
toei even those widely considered some
of the strongest of the series the
reason for this is simply due to how
anime episodes are made multiple
episodes are in production at once with
teams dedicated to each of them and they
rotate through episodes to keep the
production flowing when you have a show
with a huge number of episodes there's
only so much staff at a time that can be
able to be dedicated to them and so
Outsourcing becomes a necessity to one
allow the production to exist in the
first place and two to allow bigger
episodes to have more time for their
completion 2003's Fullmetal Alchemist
anime had 21 of its 51 episodes
outsourced that's almost two full
seasons of anime in brotherhood's 64
episode run 25 of those were entirely
outsourced too Studio names like PA
Works Goga Kobo Telecom and A1 pictures
are just a few who worked on these shows
and I'm sure some of you Savvy fans will
notice some of these support Studios
have since gone on to produce high
quality shows all on their own it
shouldn't be a surprise then that much
like the Dragon Ball example I used
earlier some of its best episodes came
from those external Studios and then
when you throw in studio bones's top
tier staff on top of that
for those that may not be aware given
how much bones has become a household
name in their own right these days the
studio was actually formed from
sunrise's strongest production team by
its producer masahiko Minami as a result
it still maintains strong ties to Mecca
animators to this very day and while
Fullmetal Alchemist doesn't exactly have
much in the way of mechs there's a work
ethic and craftsmanship that carries
over regardless its wide array of
talented animation directors will not
only correct faces from model accuracy
but often go above and beyond to elevate
the scene as a whole and really it all
comes together to explain just how these
shows maintain an absurd level of Polish
during even its lowest moments on the
2003 side of things the series is led by
director seiji mizushima who is a
lovingly nicknamed fatty by his staff
and is the person the director was based
off of in the shirubako anime I don't
think that's a nickname that's looked on
all too kindly these days but by all
accounts he was a real joy to work under
and the team had a great deal of respect
form in spite of that nickname but for
the most part his directorial experience
was Mecca related but he led the Shaman
King anime in 2001 and while that series
certainly doesn't shy away from its Mech
influences I think the ability to also
capture that fun Shonen energy made him
the perfect fit for a series like Full
Metal Alchemist for the Brotherhood
adaptation Fullmetal Alchemist found
itself directed by an animator turned
director who much likes so many of
bones's Staff also had intense ties to
Mecha anime he's someone who's being
quite vocal about his love of hayo
miyazaki's work also citing Kiki's
Delivery servers as one of the reasons
he got into anime in the first place
it's an influence you can very clearly
see in his debut show Kuro Phantom
memory it's just chock full of solid
layouts with a real emphasis on the
fundamentals of Animation however that
show was only two cores long and that
meant he was able to have a real
Hands-On approach to directing using his
strong drawing skills to really Elevate
the production itself contrast
brotherhood's 64 episodes were more than
double the length of phantom memories
and so that approach was simply never
going to work instead he had to lean
heavily on the individual directors and
storyboard artists on board the
production delegating duties like that
can be scary and sometimes leads to
jarring disparity in quality across
episodes but thankfully he was blessed
with a very strong directorial team
within bones itself and a lot of that
Outsourcing sure helped alleviate the
pressure too in the behind the scenes
sections of any other video now would be
an incredible time to talk about the
character designers for each show but I
think with both series sporting
seriously impressive design work either
way it's an element that's wholly down
to preference on the whole really 2003's
designs came from yoshiyuki Ito who's
arguably a bit of a legend in this
department he's done some spectacular
designs for the likes of Space Dandy
hiso-masso and there's a really distinct
flavor to his work that seeps into his
Full Metal Alchemist designs too they
sport a far sharper edged in the manga's
artwork and really lean into the idea of
an adaptation rather than a perfect copy
on the flip side brotherhoods came from
Hiroki Kano whose design background
really only extends to razza phone and
The UU Hakusho movie in spite of this
his work here is remarkably competent
too with a staunch adherenced arakawa's
rounder and looser style it looks great
and really helps to sell the idea that
Brotherhood exists to represent the
manga as a whole while 2003 veered off
in its own Direction by necessity
however where both series really shine
are their individual animators the key
players the major stars and I think to
do them Justice they require their own
space for a thorough exploration of what
they offer each series I'll be sure to
include their section in future videos
regarding this topic but in the meantime
I think it's important to cover an
aspect of the anime that is arguably as
defining as its visuals to music
[Music]
similar to the visual production side of
the anime it's hard to go wrong with
music for either anime adaptation of
this story both excelling their
respective approaches and bring with
them tracks and motifs that have since
become deeply beloved by nearly all who
watched the shows but what I find
interesting between both of them is that
they do have different approaches
fundamentally I mean and I think those
differences really highlight the
differences in general direction both
shows took in their adaptations the
original series score was composed by
michiru Oshima and when I first watched
it I was honestly surprised by how
grounded and earthy the whole thing felt
both scores are certainly rooted in a
sense of emotion and wonder but oshima's
Focus really seemed to be on the down to
earth aspect of the story most of the
tracks feature a lot of instrumentation
that feels familiar to us as viewers
strings horns drums the whole nine yards
whereas with Brotherhood score composed
by Akira senju it was immediately clear
to me how different the two composers
envisioned this story and its world
senju has gone on record in interviews
saying he per purposely didn't watch or
listen to the 2003 series before
composing Brotherhood but rather read
the Manga and tried to imagine up what
the world would sound like and where
Oshima heard a grounded story set in a
fantastic World senju clearly heard a
story of fantasy tragedy and hope
brotherhood's score focuses deeply on
its emotional beats and a sense of
fantasy and wonder pianos string
sections and a choral arrangements are
everywhere in this score there's a very
grandiose nature to it all it reminds me
of something like Lord of the Rings
where its music and Direction made each
moment feel like the audience was lucky
to be witnessing history in the making
for these fantastic worlds and yet
there's something that just keeps
bringing me back to oshima's 2003
approach to the show no don't get me
wrong the Brotherhood soundtrack is
packed to the brim with absolutely
wonderful works of Music helping the
adaptation Elevate its emotional beats
higher than ever before but I personally
feel really drawn to the more grounded
approach of the original Show's score as
I read through the manga the story and
its world really did feel like upbeat
characters with with Fantastical powers
that feel secondary to the conviction
and heart in the face of seemingly
Relentless negativity and impossible
odds so the direction of Leaning into
the character-driven element rather than
the Fantastical resonated with me
personally it's a direction I don't
think a lot of composers went tasked
with writing for a story as crazy as
Fullmetal Alchemist would take it very
much reminds me of John Williams's score
for Star Wars where you also had this
extremely Fantastical universe and
events but instead had the music focus
on the Earthly minutia of the characters
hell there's even a fair bit of Star
Wars trademark flugelhorn in Fullmetal
Alchemist 2. foreign
the grounded atmosphere of this
otherwise Fantastical story is what
draws me in so feverishly in a world
that's written to be filled with so many
wondrous things it stands to arakawa
that I myself am more than anything else
enthralled by the story surrounding the
two main characters and I think there's
very good reason for that once Ed and Al
arrive at izumi's place for training it
becomes clear that this section is going
to deal with predominantly one thing
flashbacks and it's interesting to sit
and read through or painted a bleak
picture of a mother dying of a sickness
we never see her have we see resentment
for a father that's never there and two
very young kids looking to move
mountains to save the only family they
have it's heartbreaking and we haven't
even seen the unnatural torturous
heartbreak yet having returned from
their training with Izumi we see the
fabled event that's been alluded to from
the very first page the transmutation
circle that almost cost them both
everything and this section is
remarkably simple looking in the manga
having come away from story is like
berserk which depict Dark Fantasy horror
better than anyone else part of me was a
little underwhelmed with how this looked
in the manga but in hindsight I'm glad
that once again the emphasis was on the
characters and their dialogue getting a
view of what happens in this
Transcendent state with Ed is a really
cool idea and I feel like it's littered
with hints for the future and the
Mystery of this series but honestly the
most traumatic part is what follows it's
the aftermath Ed's realization his
sacrifice what creature he ends up
creating and attempting to create his
own mother it's utterly horrifying and
the following reinforces the reasoning
behind why winry and Granny are so close
to these two young boys now I want to
talk more about Al and Ed at the end of
this video because I think they're
Dynamic with this world is the key to
this series but right now I'd like to
make a prediction okay it's Theory time
in the immediate chapter after these
events we get the boy's first
interaction with the government and it's
with Ron Mustang
Ron Mustang Ron Mustang that's insulting
that's okay but interestingly due to
some mistakes made on a government
recruitment document he arrives in town
to pick up the Elric Brothers thinking
that they were both in their 30s but I
think this is way too coincidental and
this story is way too tightly written
for something like that to just be
coincidence following this event Ed is
seen as someone special and seeing as we
haven't seen his father in the picture
at all I'm going to guess that he's
behind this decision maybe as a way of
protecting his kids or perhaps more
likely to take advantage of their
current circumstances as students of
Izumi and now having tried to transmute
life itself if either of these are true
then that would mean that their father
needs to be someone high up in the
government or military someone who has
access to these documents this also
explains his consistent absence I mean
it can't be Mustang he's too young it
can't be used he's too dead it could be
I'm strong the hair color matches and he
cares for them quite a lot and it could
be president Bradley too but we don't
really know much about this fellow
beyond that he has a network of
intelligence and wants the boys out of
the current investigation which tracks
with this with that said it could still
all just be coincidence the writing for
this flashback isn't perfect I mean this
is all framed if you remember as a
flashback a story Ed and Al are
recanting to Izumi upon her request but
in this we see conversations like that
with Mustang or Winery that they weren't
privy to so how could they see these
people's perspective how did you know
about the parts you weren't there for I
don't know personally but what I do know
is that Bradley seems to be following
Edward around like a Love Struck teen
lately which brings me to my favorite
part of this story so far
thank you
okay Bradley is a bad guy
damn it
I predicted this a while ago and My Hope
was to end this video with this being my
prediction now everyone's gonna think I
read ahead and just wrote something like
oh yeah this dude's totally a bad guy I
definitely didn't read I had to spoil
myself so no I'm not lying I knew it I
predicted it please believe me the
following section is the most compelling
or at the least most action-packed part
of the story so far that I've read it's
got Revelation tension and filled with
promises for the future Alphonse Elric
is tasked with rejogging his own memory
concerning the events or visions he saw
that very night he lost physically
everything according to Ed himself he
saw something that brought him closer to
the answer they needed but when it came
to Al he's forgotten everything and thus
is the goal of this next section the way
arakawa goes about it is by creating a
complicated spider's web of mixed
motivations we're introduced to the
latest and best sin greed who along with
his lackeys kidnap Al so that he can
reveal to them his secret to immortality
greed is an infectious personality
yogish and boisterous he fears little
and never stops talking he's exactly the
sort of character that makes for a
fantastic scene partner for the likes of
Al who seldom speaks in comparison on
the other side of this we have Izumi and
her husband who offers so much comedy my
sides were hurting just reading through
it I'm a big fan of the protective but
gritty Persona Izumi exudes to but the
real interest doesn't take shape until
Ed who up until this point had been
seeing to his Alchemy assessment finds
himself followed by Bradley back home
where he realizes that Al is in trouble
kidnapped
[Music]
Edward in this big brother role is
awesome to see and what's hilarious is
that greed who was up until this point
the most unstable personality once he
meets Ed he realizes what he's up
against this is a kid who isn't going to
make a deal with such a dicey figure the
fight is compelling and greed is
terrifying it makes me wonder if all the
sins are capable of showing their true
forms like this but I think the most
impactful part of all of this that
people will remember and be in awe of is
the reveal of Bradley he is a competent
fighter yes oh my God yes he's
terrifying but it's what happens in the
sewer and the meeting he has later on
with the other sins that really speaks
to the terror of this situation
the military is compromised from the
very top he is led by this old man
hooked up to a bunch of pipes maybe this
is Edward and Al's dad now I don't know
just throwing it out there it's a
complete shot in the dark but all I do
know is that Bradley was the one that
named Edward the Full Metal Alchemist
and with that being his official title
and the name of this series it makes me
wonder if there's any significance to
that name at all only time tell I think
and so bringing this video to a close I
find myself in an unfamiliar position as
a reviewer looking at this for the very
first time specifically because this
story isn't at all like what I expected
it to be and while I have only read
about one-third of this story presently
I feel like I am starting to understand
the dynamic of Alphonse and Edwards so
much more clearly now and what was once
an interesting Duo to lead this tale has
helped me better appreciate what arakawa
is trying to say with them in a profound
way a cursory glance at this story might
lead you to believe that Edward is the
most important character in the story
and that his brother alifons is a sweet
but ultimately secondary player in this
story acting only as a motivating force
to push his older more active brother
into action and while I fell prey to
that very thinking initially now I'm
embarrassed to have thought that ever
was the case for it's the dynamic these
two share in accordance with the
antagonist of this world that
effectively make up what Fullmetal
Alchemist is trying to say as a story
and I think what makes this story as
emotionally resonant As It ultimately is
but what do I mean there is a lot of
philosophy in this story however for the
purposes of this one point and
prediction I'd like to make I want to
focus on three Central points of view
starting off with Edward from the very
first page it's clear what the events
that Define Edward are in chapter 6 he's
haunted by horrific dreams brought on by
his Guild surrounding the incident right
before their first run-in with scar he
talks about how doubtful he is in the
feasibility of getting his brother his
body back when I first saw Ed meet Dr
Marco I saw this as a Starcon contrast
between two very different individuals
Dr Marco someone who's haunted by the
past sins of the government and Military
such that he Harbors deep root of
resentment projecting them onto Edward
who I thought was convincingly not
allowing his past to Define him and
instead push forward
the first time we see Edward in the
manga is at the single most traumatic
moment in his life before cutting to him
pushing forward in a light-hearted fair
it demonstrates exactly who he is as a
character tortured yes but also
tenacious and convicted working with his
trauma in a productive way and I thought
that was it for a very long time until
Ed visits his mom's grave because he's
Restless he wants to spend every single
moment pushing towards his goal making
progress on a journey that seems
hopeless all the while Al who has lost
the most out of the two is much more
inclined to insist that they rest and
enjoy the day Edward has an outwardly
good attitude towards leaving negativity
in the past but he seems to always be
focusing on it using it as a fuel with
the most pressing cost to him being his
sacrifice of the today the here and now
there's an interesting quote from Granny
panaco on Edward Elric and his nature in
this chapter too it says I wondered
where in that little body all that
strength was coming from and because
he's so strong I worry that when he does
finally find an obstacle he can't
overcome would he be able to get back on
his feet by pairing this Exposition with
the small outing Edward design to his
mother's grave it gives this chapter a
very heavy and emotional atmosphere
rooted in the mistakes of the past and
how they inform our futures not just
through Edward's tireless pursuit of
answers to his greatest problem but even
with regards to the ishpalan war that
took winry's parents and Granny pinako's
family while those events took so much
from them it very much defines how they
live now granting Prosthetics is a
successful business thanks to the war's
aftermath and similarly that horrific
past even now defines both Edward and
alphonse's lives as they know it
exemplified almost immediately after
once Ed gets his arm back for the very
first time he runs to repair his brother
without hesitation everything he does
all of this study all of the torment and
struggle is not just for himself it's
for his brother and that's what he cares
about so let's talk about Alphonse
Alphonse while having the most to gain
from this mission is the one who
interestingly is more grounded in the
here and now while he still wishes to
regain his mortal body he does so for
totally different reasons to why Edward
pushes in such a direction he wants the
body not to make up some difference and
to get even with the universe but to
instead better enjoy the here and now
there are massive ethical and physical
struggles over the morality of extending
a person's Natural Life towards
immortality in this story this is
visually demonstrated through the
horrific chimeras as well as all the
actions of the sins themselves in the
case of Alphonse he has everything the
antagonist of this story want he has an
immortal existence on this plane and
that's exactly what makes him dislike
his current existence so much because
without being able to feel pain taste
good food or feel the rain in his skin
or the wind in his hair it's all just a
muted experience A Life That's
practically meaningless and you might
think that Edward is closer to Al's
outlook on life than and the antagonist
of the story but I would argue
differently unlike Alphonse Edward is
the one to blame for the bulk of what
tragedy unfolded he led the charge and
as a result of that met a series of
crippling consequences along the way
both literally and figuratively in order
to write these wrongs he sees himself
having committed he doesn't allow his
feelings to compromise his forward
progression however in the same way the
villains of the story have their focus
squarely on the future they want for
themselves Edward's mind is consumed
with guilt over his past and nowhere is
this more evident than in Rush Valley
where we learn of his State Alchemist
pocket watch where on the inside of it
is etched a specific date the 3rd of
October a date he promised himself he
would never lose focus of for those same
reasons he destroyed his family home he
is so consumed by the guilt of that
event and the consequences he wrote on
his own family that he has dedicated
every waking moment to perfecting and
investigating this mysterious power
system in the hopes that one day it will
reveal to him something that will allow
him to move on with the rest of his life
free of guilt impossible as it seems to
be so in a way he is as good and as
talented as he is not just because he's
a genius but because he's obsessed and
perhaps that's why he denies that
compliment every single time it's
offered to him Alphonse has the
immortality that everyone is after and
yet he hates it while Ed is living in
the past and others are worried about
their Futures this is a story not just
about Equivalent Exchange but about life
itself what you need to give up on or
not give up in order to lead a
fulfilling life and ironically and
tragically Alphonse who's always telling
Ed to slow down and enjoy the moment to
rest and to have fun he seems to be the
only one who truly understands what life
is all about and that a great life needs
to be one that ends at some point and
even if we want to take a step back and
think about things more abstractly from
Ed Alphonse or any other character in
this story perhaps the lesson is that we
can't create full appreciation for
something unless we lose it first in
exchange
[Music]
next week we're going to be going on to
part two of this series I hope to see
you all there and thank you all so much
for watching
[Music]
me